[Music]
we'll start with an easy one
how do you define the self how do i
define the self
um you know the longer you work on a
question
like that uh the less prepared you are
to give an answer
i tend to make the distinction that i
did in a talk i gave
earlier today uh using classical indian
thought
and say well actually there are two
different things going on when we talk
about the self
one is um in the classical indian
context
the self is actually
the word that you would use for a very
specific idea
um the sanskrit word for it is athman
and that really is about
whether there is a
dichronic unity unity across
time to a locus of
consciousness a capacity to have a
perspective
so a debate that happens between uh
buddhist and hindu philosophers
is whether the moment of consciousness
at
any moment from which you look out to
the world
there is an awareness that things are
happening the very act of perception
so forth whether that is something that
changes from
moment to moment or is it something that
is
unified it's a particular unitary entity
across time so if i were to believe in a
self it would be that that perspective
of consciousness
from which all else flows is something
that
is the same from moment to moment across
a life
and indeed as the classical indian
philosophers would have hinted
philosophers would have said
across different lives so for me
that is actually an interesting
heuristic it's a way of thinking about
what best
explains the possibility of
experience and i therefore have a very
uh very much a philosopher's view of it
i don't particularly see
that as something that i would want to
have
a particular line on but
very often in ordinary english when we
talk about
you know ourselves we're really talking
about something that
again the saskatchewan philosophers
would have called the person
that is to say the one who has a
particular kind of
identity who has
memories has particular kinds of
psychological dispositions
who has relationships from birth through
life
who has duties who has particular kinds
of capacities or
incapacities all of those things
richly constitute who we take ourselves
to be
so when you ask you know who are you you
know
i myself think etc we are really talking
about this very rich and extended notion
of who we are
i think that there is no debate
uh philosophically that there is such a
thing about
human beings that as persons we have
this rich
psychology so then the the question
becomes and
was both common in ancient india and uh
has become so in modern western
philosophy in the last 40 50 years
what happens if some of the structural
features of your personal identity
are pulled apart what where you know
for example with amnesia or with
you know more uh exaggeratedly through
science fiction
suppose you had uh memories uh
transplanted to you
so then we start having boundary cases
and of course there is a rich
literature in psychiatry and about
disorders of
the self as it is called there which is
really about
the coherence and continuity of our
personhood
and i think that we have two options
there
either we go down the way of saying that
these kinds of undoubted uh
sort of psychotic possibilities that
human beings
encounter and the thought experiments
that allow us to think of
how our personhood might be twisted
and stretched and sometimes broken
either that suggests
that we have a very fragile view of who
we are
it's completely contingent on the ways
in which
our lives turn out things beyond us the
kind of traumas that might be
inflicted on us the pains and suffering
we might have to endure
as well as the kinds of things that
might happen to bits of our brain so
it's very fragile
or you can say yes of course that
there's that fragility
but there is so long as there is a
this underlying self this continuity
of perspective of consciousness then
there is something which is remarkably
tenacious
throughout our lives even if we forget
massively even if our life course has
changed
even if we completely have to reconsider
who we are in terms of our relationships
or who we were born to or who we love
and so forth
there is this um something stronger
something that persists as i said
tenaciously
through life and i think it is really a
matter of inclination whether we want to
think about
this very changeable mutable personhood
that we occupy across life
as very fragile in itself or is
something that
points to something much more tenacious
something much more remarkable
and continuous our ideas of the self
vary between
different cultures they also vary across
time you know you could make a
distinction between the pre-modern self
and the modern self
why is it so plastic why is our idea of
the self something that's continually
being
remodeled or affected by environmental
factors
well yes concepts of yourself in this
in this larger sense um of course
occur across time they vary they're also
contextualized
differently so it might be this uh
a sense that when we talk about what has
happened with the modern self
we're not really talking about um the
phenomenology the interior subjectivity
of people
you know it's not as if people across
time at all times
perhaps going back to even um
earlier hominid species it's not as if
they didn't have
thoughts that they kept to themselves
schemes that they had
emotions they tried to control um
expressions they wanted to convey or
hide so
there are things which are simply not
about
variation so when we talk about a modern
self
we're really talking about a way of
conceptualizing
the human person in the context
of particular operations of power
whether it be
money or whether it be social
hierarchies or whether it be
sort of larger structures within which
we work and so forth
so when we talk about a particular self
or a non-self whether we whether it's
chronologically specific or whether it's
culturally variable
we need to ask ourselves what is the
context
within which we are talking about these
variations
so some things it seems as if
evolutionarily there is
um certain kinds of continuities
which alone explain why
human beings have asked these questions
about who we are
as far as we can make out um throughout
history in different ways whether it is
in
you know classical sanskrit texts so
whether it is in
uh egyptian uh hieroglyphics whether
it's in different religious traditions
uh we people have asked these kinds of
questions which we can
see in the art in not only the
literature and the philosophical text
but in art and in ritual and in the
construction of
things like mausoleums and how we center
ourselves
in in urban planning so it's clear
that human beings have part of what
constitutes
the reflexivity of human beings is the
capacity
to ask who we are and that's relatively
unchanging if you then go back to what i
said earlier that
even you know as soon as we ask a
question about is there something like a
modern self
we're immediately saying you know we are
not talking about
the metaphysics of the self we are not
talking about necessarily the
phenomenological capacities
but we are talking about a particular
socio-political self as soon as we say
things like that we have in effect and
answers to why
our narratives of the self are so
mutable
so variable across time and across
cultures
which is that it is the context of our
enquiry into who we are
it's the purposes for which we enquire
who we are
it is the way we narrate uh and
communicate who we are to each other
that determines uh a particular local
answer so if there is anything
unchanging about the self
it is a human capacity to ask about the
self
but every answer you give is going to be
embedded and contextualized and
therefore local
and it seems as if evolutionarily we
have
developed we have evolved to have an
adaptive
concept of the self so for example if
you look at the buddha
he says there is no self in this in the
in in the context of
uh the the whether you know in the
context of saying
there isn't a diachronically um
continuous um unitary being
that generates all states of
consciousness
obviously if we are going to shift
the concept of no self to
modern um psychology you're going to say
people who lack a sense of self
are in conditions of psychiatric
breakdown
so the buddha wasn't saying let's embark
on a program
of psychiatric breakdown he was talking
about
the non-self in a particular context of
responding to
uh the conditions of suffering that he
saw so he said
on our suffering comes from a habit of
clinging to things and we cling to
things because we have
an over developed sense of who we are
such that we justify to ourselves
what we want and what we don't want and
when we don't get it as invariably in
life we don't
you have dissatisfaction and the
dissatisfaction generates more kinds of
actions which only deepen
this desire and that's what uh suffering
is in that context to say therefore
let go of who you think you are
therefore don't abide by sense of self
is very different from how a
psychiatrist might say
somebody has a breakdown in their sense
of self they don't have
continuous narratives anymore they don't
have agency they don't have capacities
to
function in life the buddha wasn't
saying that so
you can almost trivialize the deep
puzzlement about why we have
so many different you know changing
ideas of self by saying
it's all about the context and the
motivation under which we develop those
ideas
and that i think is perhaps one of the
sort of
really deep evolutionary advantages that
human beings have been able to
develop right since perhaps even pro
homo sapiens
because we're pre homo sapiens because
it is what has
allowed us to constantly locate
ourselves in relation to an
endless number of environmental contexts
and factors
fascinating and one of those contexts
and factors one of the most influential
is probably religion and how religion
influences itself
i was wondering if you could talk in a
bit more detail about that
so every religion is going to have
some sense of how it's talking about
the core of the human being the essence
of the human being however you
want to call it without
that even that is to say even say a
religious tradition
which emphasizes performativity
uh ritual action social interaction
uh political order you know even
those kinds of traditions have to say
who does these things if you are to obey
who is it who obeys if we are to
act who is it who's acting why does the
actor
need to act that way or ought to act
that way
so if you look at the larger structures
of all these religious traditions
they are trying to give an explanation
for our location within a cosmos
and to give us a particular kind of
teleology a direction a goal
towards which human beings have to go
but in order to do that they have to
tell those who are
going to follow them we're going to
adhere to them to those
uh doctrines who we are
such that we are capable of
meditation we are capable of worship
we are capable of prayer we are capable
of being open to the spirit of god
coming into us all these kinds whatever
it is the traditions
say about what reality is
it is about our relationship to reality
it is not uh akin to simply saying
we are figuring out how black holes are
formed
even though it has absolutely no bearing
on our lives religion
isn't like that religion doesn't try to
give a narrative
which has no bearing on us as soon as it
has a bearing on us
religion has to explain who we are
such that that can be a bearing on us
that's why
accounts of who we are are central
to religious traditions my line of works
in
uh cancer i talk to people who have
have had or have loved someone with
cancer and i work with them to turn
their experience into
narratives and stories and that they can
share cancer places and not just cancer
you know terminal illness and
significant illness
places a real strain on people's sense
of self
i think it's a real challenge
to the identity that people have i don't
know you know i may be [ __ ]
long training here but i was i i i'd be
interested to hear you talk about
illness in the self so what is the
relationship
people have with themselves as they face
serious and especially terminal illness
there we are caught in i think a
profound dilemma
the more robust the sense of who you are
um your perhaps your religious identity
uh perhaps your conviction in an
afterlife
perhaps your awareness of
what kind of actions uh have led you to
this point
um such that you might be prepared for
death
whatever the that account the stronger
you have a sense of self
of yourself the
greater the
challenge you seem to face
about its extinction
on the other hand going towards death
um without
being too worried about what extinction
is
expecting that you
are simply going to seize
because you do not have a close grasp
on who you are might seem as if it is
therapeutically
preferable but it could have been
arrived at
only if you had had a life in which you
had an insecure grasp of yourself
and that and that leads to all kinds of
problems in relating to people in
directing your life and so forth
so there is this sense that the
condition of a good life
makes a good death more difficult what
might seem to make
a good death easier is incompatible with
most of what we think is a good life
so the transition is somehow
to arrive uh at
the uh threshold of death
with a robust sense of who we are
and what we have done and how
we have constituted ourselves up to this
point
but that at that point in
confronting the immediate inevitability
rather than the long-term inevitability
that we all have in confronting the in
the imminent inevitability of death to
somehow
transform that robust
grasp we have on who we are
into one that is more comfortable
with letting go and i think that
that uh
move perhaps psychologically comes
perhaps easier to some people than
others
which is why it seems as if you look at
people's lives
and you might not necessarily find
somebody
having lived a life of sufficient
reflexive discipline you just find some
people
more at ease with
the death coming and others who find it
much more terrifying i think part of
that
is simply to do with whether people are
so constituted
that they can make that transition from
having a robust sense of themselves to
nevertheless
feeling that that sense of self can be
let go
of if it is not possible there are some
people who might be inclined
to train themselves to
being at ease with letting go
but that could be actually terribly
dangerous
and painful for others for whom
that inclination isn't there that way of
confronting
the letting go of oneself at the
prospect of death
isn't what comes naturally and at that
point
we have absolutely nothing to do except
to be with them through that
inevitable point of extinction towards
which they fearfully travel
and then there is only sympathy
no therapy where do you
see our ideas of self or our idea of
self
going i'm not sure
whether the
novelty of history at this point
is sufficient to
[Music]
make me expect that there is anything
predictable
about changes in the ways people
think of themselves or narratives about
how people ought to think of themselves
changes two three reasons for that
one is that of course every generation
in every culture thinks of itself by
definition
as living in unprecedented time and
they're literally
right so that has always been the case
so the the novelty and the complexity
that
we look at will not be very different
in phenomenological terms how we feel
than how
the aztecs might have felt in the 14th
century or how
the people of great zimbabwe might have
felt in the 10th century and so forth
and so on
so i think that to some extent we might
overs
we i don't think that anything that we
are
however complex technologically we are
at the moment
the experience of unprecedentedness is
there all the time and so people are
going to be
no different i think 10 years 20 years
50 years from now
than they were between um
you know 3500 bce and 3200 bce
the other thing is really uh my going
back to
this point that i think that adaptive
narratives of the sense of oneself
is i think a fundamental feature of
human evolution
so if you're going to be thinking in
evolutionary time
then although we have no idea what
happens to homo sapiens
whether it's become so supremely adapted
that environments
are adapting to it
rather than it adapting to environments
even if you think of it that way
if there are going to be changes in this
feature
of what i've been arguing is um is is
constitutive
of homo sapiens which is these
constantly adaptive senses of self
then that's just going to carry on as it
always has
so we have a much much deeper question
is this the end of homo sapiens have we
got anywhere else to go
might there be a post-human future and
therefore
might there be different evolutionary
adaptations perhaps there might be a way
in which
uh the environment in which that species
functions is such that
having one monotonic robust
account of self for all occasions
becomes the adaptively efficient
uh you know natural selection unlike
with us
where adaptability seemed to have been
that
you know that process that has helped us
the most
and then finally i think we have another
reason
why i think it becomes very difficult to
say are we going to change
which is that yes there is greater
interconnectivity
so yes there is um
[Music]
less of a sense of um
we alone possess an account these days
you can bust that by just going on
online and pointing to you know some
article and saying look
this is what we know we have the
evidence for
how the sumerians were thinking about it
so it's not something that
the french invented the 16th century
something like that
yes so we do have a greater flow
now what i'm genuinely unsure of
is whether this particular
unprecedentedness that
that connectivity that you're talking
about whether that
unprecedented circulation of
uh both in terms of quantity and you
know the number of ideas but also the
speed and
thoroughness with which ideas circulate
around the world
that is unprecedented and if
all the time we are talking and we are
confronted with how radically different
accounts of who we are
our senses of self um come up to our
knowledge
is that going to make a difference is it
for the first time in history going to
make a difference that
being able to look at and simultaneously
entertain you know 20 25 30 however many
different accounts of who we are
is that going to make a difference is
that is there going to be a
convergence i think we are at a point
where convergence doesn't look
uh possible because of the fact that
the the global interconnections is
actually leading to an explosion
of new ideas rather than an agreement
on a particular idea but who knows
perhaps in 50 years time or 100 years
time
there might be convergence towards some
rather than
other narratives of who we are but i
couldn't possibly
uh predict that for more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the institute
of art and ideas at iai tv
you